we should talk about the tea food [ __ ]
yeah I'm honestly I was kind of I'm not
really tapped in on that I mean I'm just
like just from bankses tweets that's our
that's all I really want to talk about
bro you were my [ __ ] you are my
family dog
people eat off this [ __ ] cool yeah man
it's just like I don't know man I met
him before he's a really nice guy
Thanks he's just like the most dramatic
dude ever yeah like his tweet like I
don't know like to me it was like and
then today he one of his most recent
tweets it was like people keep telling
me to get the [ __ ] off Twitter like I'm
sorry I'm so heated and blah blah blah
it's like no but you should you should
yeah just don't just don't
justjust don't tweet about it I mean you
got a multi-family you've known him for
like a year
just just a business partner and I get
it he's a friend he's a good friend I
get that you hear me back kiss him on
the lips get some on the lips yeah
he's your family yeah kiss him on the
lips take a bath naked yeah get in the
pool with all the other phase brothers
okay and get naked in there mhm okay I'm
gonna take a picture 10 years later and
kiss each other on the lips yeah as well
yeah sorry that Rooney yeah yeah I love
you too
[Music]
you're the best baby Bubba ever
I know you'd never see us TiVo my little
baby brother what I'd take care of you
you gotta kiss him on the forehead and I
carry him around you can go to Walmart
and get a family picture yeah yeah got
like a vlog with my new baby brother
teef ooh yeah yeah the phase family
vlogs yeah god damn it bro oh yeah just
like I was so apparently apparently T
foo so suing them right right and for
like having an overbearing contract or
something like that and banks was
basically like
listen we've offered to change your
contract like multiple times
blah blah blah like missus we've only
collected 60 grand from you when you've
made millions here's what we offered you
all this [ __ ] and he's like yeah but
like my in the beginning my contract was
super overbearing and I'm just trying to
protect other gamers that are coming up
from signing these contracts because
it's it's kind of like an industry
standard now it's kind of like I guess I
I would see like a parallel being the
music industry where someone starts
popping a little bit and labels son make
them sign their life away
yeah then two years later when they're
really popping yeah they date all the
labels get all the money right I think
gaming is like similar sure so easy TV
was like was like I'm trying to change
this and I want this to be known that
like this is [ __ ] up yeah that the
gaming industry is the same way anyways
there's a there's his brother deemed
keemstar I guess and said and said teeth
who wants to start his own organization
that's why I he's doing all this he
wants to get out so that he can start
his own [ __ ] and some banks replied and
was like what happened to this like
looking out for the commoner and the
then the Nepean home it'd be a home but
to me I'm like just [ __ ] obviously he
wants to start his own [ __ ] he can start
his own [ __ ] and make better contracts
maybe that's what he's planning on doing
ya know but teeth was like Herman banks
is like you with the fall kappa new
would ever see this is this is you big
two-faced man you're hiding behind your
team and all this [ __ ] it's like just be
a friend and and tweet me dog like no
but like now another way that yeah
unfortunately this is i mean i get i
agree he's you call you should give you
a call still be a friend you know i'm
saying but like yeah but like if he
wants to make moves right now while he's
popping he wants to dominate the world
his own industry with his own
organization yeah he's gotta [ __ ] do
it man it's like that famous picture and
it's super out of context it's funny
people always reference this image of
jay-z and dame - and I forget whether
interview is for but Dame is like real
animated and jay-z's in the back like
like just blank face and everyone uses
that like that face when you buy a
[ __ ]
like leave Dame Dash and like go on and
like kill the music industry by herself
yeah and J like comments is like
actually in that moment I wasn't even
thinking about anything like I was just
like kind of just like zoned out but it
just like the timing of it was perfect
like that's because he left right after
or what yeah yeah I forget the timeline
but he went on to like you know do his
own thing and and we become who he
became yeah and outgrew Dame like huge
and so that's that's what I think is
going on right here is banks being like
and what you mean gonna leave the brand
son what you mean gonna try to be bigger
than me and teef was like yeah I'm gonna
do that actually uh-huh I'm the number
one [ __ ] fortnight's streamer I don't
need you guys to tell me I'm cool that's
what I feel like I kind of feel like
he's just a he's just like a like an
actual like beast you know you know he's
like I feel like he there's no there's
no other path for him but like being
unbelievably successful yeah for some
reason I just get maybe was the fact
that he like moved to LA for a little
bit and then like move back because he
liked it like wasn't focusing do you
hear what his opinion was on that I
didn't watch his response no no no not
that I mean like it was like it was like
a clip stream clip that was hilarious
people like why don't you live in LA he
was like um yeah at least cool if you
want to like party and like kind of like
waste time but I need to be gaming like
that's it play him he's like I need to
be the best they I need to be practicing
so he's like and the internet sucks the
Internet's way better here so yeah it's
like that to me that the fact there is
no like the social aspect didn't even
matter yeah I'm a dear you man I hate I
hate the way all this should changes so
quickly though because I know [ __ ]
two days from now there's gonna be
another video that that's gonna make our
buzz bite our tongues comes out is like
the worst person on earth I know I want
to I want to listen to his response
to be really short and to the point
first I want to say all the stuff about
the gambling and the stunts the drinking
I told my lawyer I did not want that in
there and he will do exactly just that
he will take it out so that is it no
worries that is out of my way what I
really want to talk about is the main
points I'd everyone have said anybody I
never want to bring that stuff in I
never wanted to get anybody to get
emotional because this isn't about that
this is about me in this contract this
contract that I signed when I didn't
know any better I'm an idiot
I'd never signed it in the first place
it's three-year contract what is in this
contract is so bizarre it's so [ __ ]
I wish you guys could see this thing
because I can't can't even fathom it
this contract basically allows any point
to three years to just [ __ ] take all
my heart earnings all my hard work and
just strip it over 49% over 79% these
what isn't this contracts insane that's
the worst parts okay hmm
oh wow look at this right here for
tonight competitive t fus contract the
blast calm oh nice okay right on time
yeah what does it say a goddamn summary
in this moment
that's bright this just came out or what
okay the contract states phase will pay
t food 2,000 per month as a fixed fee
plus all other income including but not
limited to salaries with a generated in
connection with the gamers services
whether individually or as part of the
team creator code income is 50/50 brand
deals 50/50 what okay wait brand deals
featuring the gamer that exists on gamer
or company content creation platforms
what twitch and YouTube so they're
taking 50% of his YouTube and twitch
income really
then why the [ __ ] was Bank saying I
should whether if the deal is brought to
the gamer by the company Oh
oh my god okay if he brings a brand deal
to the company so he goes this person
hit me up I'm gonna do this brand deal
they go cool they take 50% of that if
they give him a brand deal as in hey G
fuel wants to work with you they get 80
he gets 20 that was that was the D that
was the [ __ ] that they collected on yeah
but they said they didn't collect on any
of the other [ __ ] but I think it's more
its principle yeah it's the fact that
they can yeah and I and like I think in
t fus mind what he's doing is he's like
he looked at his bank account and he
goes holy [ __ ] his lawyer goes yo you
realize your contract they can take half
of this right now
yeah or 80% of it right now and he goes
oh [ __ ] so he's like and he had no idea
that that was the case yeah so that was
like pumps first contract yeah and they
he got out yeah which is crazy but he
was 16 he signed his [ __ ] life away I
mean what the water then what what else
what what other move do you have when
you're young and you got no money and
you'll just want to get you making music
that's why yeah you have to
it's brutal that way I was actually
thinking about that the other day we
could we we've tracked two new tracks
with the boy diamond pistols yep and
yeah new music coming out soon you guys
and I was thinking about that and like
how much Christian and Spock both
support us in terms of like knowledge
experience all that [ __ ] and I was just
thinking man like a little nas X's story
and co method zine story and and all
that like trying to like you hear all
these horror stories of like a label
right but if you're just a dude making
music or a person and you're just trying
to pop it's pretty like how like are you
good you're [ __ ] the audio is making
weird it's just that's the reflex baby
so a little gremlin inside you right now
design that's that's the devil actually
come out of my body
we're gonna do the first audio-only
exorcism the power of Christ compels you
yeah what what the [ __ ] what else could
you do like it's such a risky feeling to
be like all right do I do I take I mean
this is what's is why I brought up this
tweet so there's this tweet that someone
sent out the other day said how LeBron
grew up on welfare moved over 12 times
sleeping on friends couch no ride to
school after all that he looked at
Reebok exec in the eye and turned down a
ten million dollar check as a teenager
16 years ago today he signed for 90
million Wow you gotta just know that
you're the [ __ ] best mm-hmm yeah so
TIFF who's having his LeBron moment
exactly well now he know he would have
never signed if that was true he's out
in his pomp moment is it oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's crazy sick to get a lawyer
and just be like [ __ ] sue him yeah
I'm getting out of this [ __ ] one way or
another it's only a three year contract
too but I mean that's like that's like
millions of like you went from zero to
[ __ ] making millions in like six
months
that's crazy I mean at least I barely
dabble in twitch and it's it's been
great for me so I can only imagine for
him like how at that scale X but yo bro
make him easily [ __ ] 1,500 km month
probably but I mean there's a reason for
that like his skill level is [ __ ]
wild you know it like sat and watched
him play for like 30 minutes
no yes yeah he's amazing dudes an artist
yeah he's a hard-ass - he's an artist
with the drum gun yeah he paints
pictures man I love watching the way he
moves just incredible
not trying to flex and I'm holding half
his bags I'm trying to place not trying
to flex take your fish to Northland
break that's not a flex